cette annonce en tout cas met un terme à
des mois de rumeurs y compris bien sûr
pendant la campagne présidentielle où le
couple avait focalisé l'attention et où
beaucoup avaient estimé que les
relations privées avait parfois une
incidence sur les décisions publiques
retour sur une histoire hors norme avec
chef dit un verre cette image là avait
fait plaisir aux militants
ségolène et françois rien que tous les
deux à la tribune d'un meeting
ce ne sera arrivé qu'une fois pendant la
campagne présidentielle
car on le sait maintenant le soir de la
défaite de ségolène royal ce n'est déjà
plus un couple qui est en discussion
dans le bureau de françois hollande ce
soir là c'est un simple duo politique la
candidate par le premier secrétaire et
explique peut-être par ce geste sa
stratégie ségolène royal françois
hollande trajectoire politique et
histoire personnelle semelle depuis le
premier jour en 78 leur rencontre à
l'ena en 80 les voilà ensemble à
l'elysée au service de françois
mitterrand embauché par jacques attali
et golan et sérieuse grave engagé
françois et drôle léger c'est que je ne
m'en sens ne pourrait pas fait autre
chose que la politique françois poitout
tâche est sur autre chose que la
politique leur carrière connaît une
ascension presque symétrique et lui la
même année à l'assemblée
ségolène royal enchaîne les ministères
tandis que françois hollande gravi les
marches de l'appareil du ps
c'était le temps où il se complétait une
espèce d'arbitrage entre un conflit très
moderne au fond un cancan ségolène royal
a été ministre au fond françois hollande
a accepté de ne pas l'être mais il a
pris la tête du parti
un couple apparemment unis et jalousé
alors que le ps se déchire sur la
question européenne
royal et hollande sont les couvertures
des magazines et s'affichent ensemble au
traditionnel rassemblement des
socialistes à la rochelle les photos de
ségolène royal trône alors en bonne
place dans le bureau de françois
hollande qui apprécient cette façon de
faire de la politique
le faire 2 jeudi et quand même plus
facile plus rassurant et
plus doux pourquoi tout va changer en
2005 alors que ségolène royal fait
connaître ses premières ambitions
présidentielles
oui révèle-t-elle elle songe à être
candidate je suis fan de fausse modestie
mots et donc de voir c'est à partir de
cette période que certains bruits
commencent à courir sur leur couple
peut-être pour tordre le cou à la rumeur
il ya un an ségolène royal évoque l'idée
d'un mariage avec le père de ses quatre
enfants un mariage à tahiti
l'égalisation est gentil très romantique
pas de mariage finalement mes hommes
premier divorce politique
début 2007 françois hollande promet des
hausses d'impôts pour ceux qui gagnent
plus de 4000 euros
ségolène royal est obligé de le recadrer
cafouillage alors que la campagne
présidentielle démarre tout juste
la suite sera en apparence très loyal le
premier secrétaire mais le parti et
toute sa machine au service de la
candidate
mais après la défaite ils ont de plus en
plus de mal à accorder leurs violons
démonstration législatives ségolène
royal annonce qu'elle a téléphoné à
françois bayrou françois hollande a
l'air de le découvrir
chacun peut appeler qu'il veut
heureusement dans une démocratie
téléphonique avait le sentiment qu'il
s'expliquait par médias interposés ce
qui laissait supposer donc qui ne se
parlaient plus quand tu qu'à leurs
discussions privées non médiatique était
devenu compliqué il y a une semaine
manuel valls se plaignait de voir la vie
ne sont pas retournés au tour de la vie
d'un couple
c'est aussi pour en finir avec ces
phrases qui faisait mal
ségolène royal en particulier a voulu
clarifier la situation
voilà donc pour le parti